An educational side hustle?
A pandemic-themed holiday song?
There's a lot you may not know about The Tonight
Show's Jimmy Fallon.
Many comedians have dark pasts that fuel their
need for laughter, but Jimmy Fallon had it
pretty well growing up by all accounts.
The future host of "The Tonight Show" was
born in New York City to happy parents Gloria
and James Fallon.
As he'd later describe to Vanity Fair, his
childhood was picture perfect.
He elaborated —
"My grandparents were so happy, everyone in
the family was funny, and there was no divorce,
no unemployment."
Nevertheless, like many childhoods, Fallon's
was full of rules: his parents were strict
in terms of what he was allowed to watch and
where he was allowed to go.
There was eventually an exception to that
rule, however: the NBC sketch comedy program
"Saturday Night Live."
As a teenager, Fallon became obsessed with
the show.
He would stay up late every Saturday night
to watch it, a tradition he continues now
with his wife and children.
Aside from "Saturday Night Live," Fallon was
an avid listener of "The Dr. Demento Show,"
which introduced the world to comedy acts
like "Weird" Al Yankovic.
Fallon's family was the perfect audience for
his own early attempts at comedy, including
impressions of Dana Carvey and Pee-Wee Herman.
Soon enough, Fallon would be on his way to
becoming an ambitious new face on the comedy scene.
Before Jimmy Fallon was fully committed to
his future as a comedian, his other job prospects
were influenced by other aspects of his upbringing.
The Fallons were a family of devout Irish
Catholics, which led a young Jimmy to consider
becoming a priest.
While many would feel inclined to do this
out of a deep respect for their religion,
Fallon had more of an interest in the pageantry
of the church, which he became acquainted
with as an altar boy.
As Fallon later recalled, being an altar boy
was his first experience with being in front
of a crowd, but eventually it became clear
he was desperate for a little more validation.
He echoed this idea on Mike Birbiglia's "Working
It Out" podcast in 2022, mentioning that being
a funny priest seemed much easier than being
a funny comedian.
Still, Fallon's interest in comedy eventually
thrust him into the much higher stakes world
of stand-up.
Fallon performed stand-up comedy on the side
during his college years, often taking the
bus from The College of Saint Rose in Albany
to the famous Caroline's Comedy Club in Times Square.
Though his early attempts at telling jokes
trended more towards Andy Kaufman-esque stunts,
he found a small amount of success through
impressions, which guided him towards the
next stage of his burgeoning comedy career.
"First up, Mr. John Travolta…”
“Geezlikethanksforhavingmeisweartogodthesethingsaresoweirdoverhereright?"
After dropping out of college in 1995, Jimmy
Fallon moved to Los Angeles with the goal
of pursuing comedy full-time — a prospect
many have tried, but few have successfully
been able to do.
Nevertheless, his ambition was noticed by
Hollywood professionals, eventually gaining
him a manager and earning him his first few
dollars on stage.
He enrolled in improv classes with The Groundlings,
a historic comedy school with alumni including
Conan O'Brien, Tyra Banks, and Dax Shepard.
It wasn't long before Fallon started to sneak
his way into film and TV.
He landed his first TV gig with a guest appearance
as a photographer in the second season of
ABC's "Spin City," a late '90s sitcom starring
Michael J. Fox and Richard Kind.
Believe it or not, Fallon's casting on "Spin
City" may be owed to a certain future Avenger.
During a 2023 episode of "The Tonight Show,"
Fallon and Chris Evans discussed the fact
that, around the time that Fallon appeared
on "Spin City," Evans was an intern in the
casting office.
"I think you may have cast me—"
"Did I give you your first job?!"
"Wow!
This is…
I feel like I owe my whole career to you!"
"Yeah, that's amazing!"
Still, performing on "SNL" would remain Fallon's
white whale for years to come.
Jimmy Fallon's determination to be a cast
member on "Saturday Night Live" didn't wane
during his time in Los Angeles, and his opportunity
to audition finally came when he was just
21 years old.
He didn't impress the show's producers enough
to earn a spot on the cast or as a writer
— and for a moment, Fallon's childhood dream
seemed crushed.
While others would have taken this loss as
the end of their journey, Fallon kept his
chin up.
Over the next two years, he accrued more experience
and TV roles, including a pilot for The WB network.
Fallon was deadly serious about his ambitions:
he recounted to Rolling Stone —
"I remember saying to myself, 'If I don't
make it on 'Saturday Night Live' before I'm
25, I'm going to kill myself.'"
Fortunately, things didn't come to that, as
Fallon got a second chance to audition in 1997.
His winning bit was a parade of celebrity
impressions, which included Jerry Seinfeld,
Chris Rock, and Adam Sandler, which pulled
a rare laugh from "SNL" producer Lorne Michaels.
"So I was like, I was like — 'Yeah, my mom,
uh, wants me to go on this walkathon, and
I keep telling her, you know, SHABADEDOO!'"
Fallon joined the cast of Season 24 in 1998.
After his audition, "Saturday Night Live"
head writer Tina Fey testified that Fallon
was truly prepared to be a part of the cast.
Fey recalled Fallon's audition to Vanity Fair,
saying —
"He's one of two people I've ever seen who
was completely ready to be on the show."
Luckily, Fey's hunch proved correct, as Fallon
quickly won over audiences with the same Adam
Sandler impression that won over Lorne Michaels.
Seemingly overnight, Jimmy Fallon went from
struggling stand-up comic to the latest "SNL" star.
He appeared in recurring sketches like The
Boston Teens with Rachel Dratch and had many
amusing instances of breaking character and
cracking up with fellow cast member Horatio Sanz.
Fallon famously broke during the iconic "More
Cowbell" sketch, as well as one disastrous
edition of Debbie Downer at Disney World.
"I can't have children!"
Fallon's escapades, partially with Sanz, weren't
just limited to their on-air hijinks.
Notably, the two took full advantage of "Saturday
Night Live's" culture of partying and alcohol,
staying out into the early hours of the morning
drinking and getting into occasional bar fights.
Sanz later recounted to Vulture —
"We definitely fed into the fact that being
out of control is good on that show."
"Saturday Night Live" quickly increased Jimmy
Fallon's celebrity profile, as the comedian
was upgraded from featured player to main
cast member after only one season.
Fallon later gained even more notoriety when
he began co-hosting "Weekend Update" alongside
Tina Fey during his third season on the show.
Around the same time, Fallon played a minor
role in Cameron Crowe's 2000 film "Almost
Famous," as promotional manager Dennis Hope.
Eventually, Fallon ended up being chosen to
host various award shows for MTV over the
years, including the MTV Movie Awards and
the Video Music Awards.
While hosting the former in 2005, Fallon first
encountered a trio of writers and sketch comedians
known as The Lonely Island, consisting of
Andy Samberg, Akiva Schaffer, and Jorma Taccone.
Their unique sense of humor caught Fallon's
attention.
Fallon ended up recommending the trio's online
content to the producers of "Saturday Night
Live," and before long, Lorne Michaels invited
them to audition.
Samberg joined the show as a cast member with
Jorma and Akiva as writers, and the three
completely changed "SNL" for the digital age.
Even after each of them moved on from the
show, the members of The Lonely Island have
appeared on "The Tonight Show" on occasion.
Jimmy Fallon eventually departed from "Saturday
Night Live" following Season 29 in 2004, after
which he was replaced as Tina Fey's "Weekend
Update" co-anchor by Amy Poehler.
Fortunately, the future looked bright for
Fallon, as he had just starred in his first
lead film role alongside Queen Latifah in
"Taxi."
However, the film ended up doing poorly at
the box office when it was released that same
year, despite Fallon's performance charming
some reviewers.
Fallon's second chance came with a role he
seemed better suited for in the 2005 romantic
comedy "Fever Pitch" opposite Drew Barrymore.
The film centers on the romance between Fallon's
character, a devout Boston Red Sox fanatic,
and Barrymore's, a workaholic who doesn't
understand his obsession.
However, "Fever Pitch" also saw a lackluster
return at the box office, while reviews from
critics and viewers were also generally lukewarm.
"Are you saying that she's out of my league?!"
"She's bringing some serious heat, man.
I don't know if you got the bat speed."
"Oh, I got the bat speed."
Following the failure of "Fever Pitch," Fallon
hit a surprising dead end in his career.
Once film offers stopped rolling in, Fallon
decided to move back to New York City, eventually
hitting a depressive period with no real insight
on how he'd go forward.
However, all he ended up having to do was
wait for an old mentor to come knocking with
the opportunity of a lifetime.
Even though it left his career at a standstill,
Fallon has a lot to thank "Fever Pitch" for.
Through his work on the film, he ended up
falling in love with Nancy Juvonen, the co-founder
of Drew Barrymore's production company Flower
Films.
Fallon and Juvonen later recounted the specifics
of their first introduction to each other
during an episode of "The Tonight Show: At
Home Edition," when he produced episodes of
the show with his family during the initial
COVID-19 lockdowns in 2020.
On a walk outside their home, Juvonen recounted
how they first met at "Saturday Night Live"
when Barrymore was hosting, and Fallon eagerly
introduced himself to her.
Juvonen added that she later developed a crush
on Fallon on the set of "Fever Pitch," after
a producer brought their kids to set and she
noticed him playing with them.
"I think that's when my heart just sort of…
melted even more."
"Awww.
I remember those kids, oh they were so cute."
"Yeah!"
The two got married in 2007 and currently
live in New York with their two daughters,
who were born in 2013 and 2014.
Fallon's wedding to Juvonen wasn't without
hijinks, as one would expect from a comedian's
wedding.
As he later recounted on "The Drew Barrymore
Show" in 2020, his wedding was crashed by
none other than Kermit the Frog after the
videographer heard their wedding song would
be "The Rainbow Connection."
Although it was a perfect wedding regardless,
Kermit made it into every shot of the wedding video.
Following Jimmy Fallon's career slump after
his failure in the world of movies, Lorne
Michaels made good on a promise he made to
Fallon shortly before the comedian left "Saturday
Night Live."
At the time, Michaels and Tina Fey both suggested
that Fallon could be a good replacement for
Conan O'Brien on "Late Night" when he eventually
took over "The Tonight Show" from Jay Leno.
However, Michaels probably didn't expect that
recommending Fallon for the job in 2007 would
result in conflict with NBC executives.
As Fallon later told GQ —
"NBC was like, 'This is going to flop.
This is going to be like Chevy Chase’s show.'"
Michaels remained supportive of Fallon despite
the comedian's failure as a film star.
Nevertheless, those executives were proven
right when "Late Night with Jimmy Fallon"
debuted in 2009, as some critics considered
the host a step down from Conan.
However, Fallon slowly began to win over audiences,
especially as public behind-the-scenes turmoil
hit "The Tonight Show with Conan O'Brien."
The relatively drama-free "Late Night with
Jimmy Fallon" became a sanctuary for upbeat,
positive comedy.
Fallon's success on late night TV was, inevitably,
all thanks to Lorne's confidence, as he had
become a mentor figure for the comedian during
his six years at "SNL."
Fortunately, Fallon lucked out with perhaps
the best house band in all of late night:
The Roots, who made the show something truly
worth watching.
Fallon taped "Late Night" at 30 Rockefeller
Center, where he continued his talk show tenure
after inheriting "The Tonight Show" from Jay
Leno in 2014.
This also kept him in close proximity to "Saturday
Night Live," where he has returned to host
three times so far over the years.
The comedian also made an appearance alongside
Justin Timberlake in the sketch series' 40th
anniversary special in 2015, which gathered
a who's who of Hollywood icons to celebrate
the show with reunion sketches, tributes,
and musical performances.
The most memorable part of the night, however,
took place after the cameras stopped rolling.
The cast, crew, and audience of "SNL 40" gathered
at the Plaza Hotel for what would become the
most legendary after-party in the history
of "Saturday Night Live."
Fallon recounted the event the next night
on "The Tonight Show," revealing that there
was no scheduled musical performer, with the
party instead arranged to have an empty stage
and instruments for anyone to jam.
After unintentionally accepting duties as
the party's emcee, Fallon roped in all sorts
of musical performers.
Taylor Swift, Paul McCartney and Michael Bolton
all played their hits, but the true highlight
of the night came when Prince played "Let's
Go Crazy" to a starstruck audience of A-listers.
While his tenure on "The Tonight Show" has
mostly been a good time, Jimmy Fallon also
had to host while dealing with tragedy in
his personal life.
In 2017, the talk show host canceled a week
of shows when his mother Gloria suddenly passed
away — and his first episode back was a
rollercoaster of emotions.
"She would squeeze my hand three times and
say 'I love you.'
And I would squeeze back, 'I love you too.'"
Taylor Swift was in town to perform on "Saturday
Night Live," and she agreed to be the musical
guest at the last minute in support of Fallon.
The moment was made even more special when
Swift came on to perform the ballad "New Year's
Day" off her 2017 album "Reputation," which
contains the line —
"You squeeze my hand three times in the back
of the taxi."
In a Twitter thread posted shortly after the
episode, "The Tonight Show" producer Mike
DiCenzo revealed that, since the album had
just been released days earlier, everyone
was shocked to hear the line that paralleled
Fallon's story.
The host ended up in tears, and when the song
ended he gave Swift a heartfelt embrace.
The song's producer, Jack Antonoff — a friend
of Fallon and frequent collaborator of Swift
— also tweeted praise for the performance
and moment the next day.
The COVID-19 pandemic derailed many things,
including the world of late-night TV.
Jimmy kFallon embraced his time in quarantine
by filming episodes of "The Tonight Show"
in his home with the help of his family, which
made for a charming escape from the grim state
of the world.
However, as the pandemic continued into 2021,
Fallon decided he wanted to do a little more
to help people escape their struggles.
Recorded at New York City's Electric Lady
Studios, Fallon released a collaboration with
Ariana Grande and Megan Thee Stallion titled
"It Was A...
(Masked Christmas)."
Fallon described his intent behind the song
to the Associated Press, saying —
"I wanted to write something reflecting on
how tough it was for everyone last year during
the holidays and that it's gonna get better."
The song covers relatable topics such as getting
booster vaccines, staying masked in public,
and participating in family Zoom sessions.
"It Was A ... (Masked Christmas)" is only
the most recent in a long history of Christmas-themed
singles from Fallon.
In the past, he duetted with the legendary
Dolly Parton for a cover of Mariah Carey's
"All I Want For Christmas is You," and he
also performed Paul McCartney's iconic "Wonderful
Christmastime" with the former Beatle, The
Roots, and the cast of "Sing" back in 2016.
However, this 2021 tune was his first original
Christmas classic.
Aside from hosting "The Tonight Show" since
2014, Jimmy Fallon has also made a career
for himself as an author of children's books.
This journey started for Fallon in 2015, when
he was inspired by recent fatherhood to write
"Your Baby's First Word Will Be Dada."
In an interview with NPR, Fallon described
the book's premise as an act of selfishness,
explaining how he tried to trick his daughter
into saying the word "Dada."
He joked —
"I would call everything in the house 'dada.'"
Fallon continued to regularly release children's
books over the years, all inspired by his
experiences as a parent.
He even channeled his love for Christmas into
a 2020 book titled "5 More Sleeps 'Til Christmas."
However, his most adventurous experience came
in 2022, when he collaborated with none other
than Jennifer Lopez on a children's book titled
"Con Pollo: A Bilingual Playtime Adventure."
This team effort aims to teach kids Spanish
with the help of a lovable chicken amigo.
"Eating chicken."
"No, you're not eating the chicken in this.
This — you're friends with the chicken."
"Your friends eat the chicken."
"No one eats the chicken."
Though the team-up between Fallon and Lopez
may seem random, it was something they both
had wanted to do for a long time.
Fallon told People that approaching Lopez
to write the book with him was inspired by
his respect for her as a mother, saying —
"One of the many things I love about her is
how great of a mom she is."
What started for Fallon as a way to channel
his parenting anxieties has now become a successful
side venture for the comic.
By 2023, Jimmy Fallon had accomplished a lot
in his career, much of which he probably never
anticipated when he was just a struggling
actor.
While the comedian has plenty to look forward
to in his future, one bucket list item for
him has recently been crossed off.
In 2022, Fallon invited Cameron Crowe onto
"The Tonight Show" to promote a Broadway adaptation
of his movie "Almost Famous," which Fallon
appeared in over 20 years earlier.
On the show, Crowe personally invited Fallon
to reprise his role as Dennis Hope onstage
at some point before "Almost Famous" closed
in January 2023, which Fallon accepted.
Sadly, Fallon never made good on his promise
to Crowe, but he did make a special appearance
during one of the last nights of the musical's
run on Broadway.
After attending a performance with Lin-Manuel
Miranda and Crowe, Fallon was pulled on stage
by one of the cast members during their ending
bows, which was met with roaring applause
from the audience.
It's clear that Fallon has come a long way
from where his career was at the turn of the
century — and that he won't be going anywhere
anytime soon.